okay you want to know how to program a
Ford key and keep us stay tuned hello
I'm Derek and welcome to hindsight 101
well you learn about things that will
help you in everyday life I'm gonna show
you how to program your key and your key
fob yes there are two different things
even though they are connected this will
work for this type of key and also the
key that's just a key and a separate key
fob this will work for all 2004 Ford
vehicles or later full disclosure I did
have some camera troubles and I had to
re-record so this key is already
programmed but I guarantee you this
works you can see I have two Ford keys
and then I also have this key here which
I got from eBay so what we're going to
do is you need two keys in order for
this to work so if you don't have two
keys you're gonna have to go to the
dealership go to a locksmith or sir some
hardware stores do it as well so let's
get started you want to take the key put
it in the ignition you're going to hear
a chime then you have five seconds with
the other key in then you put the second
key in and then you have ten seconds to
put the key and you want to program
chime have five seconds put the key in
chime you got ten seconds you put in the
key you want to program now that key is
programmed but you're going to notice
that the buttons don't work so what
you're going to have to do is put it in
program mode to get the buttons to work
I'm gonna show you how to do that now
you're going to take one of your keys
and you have to turn it eight times in
the on position but you don't have to
turn the car on and then this will put
it in program mode
you know you're in program mode when you
hear the doors lock so now what you want
to do is hit the lock button on all the
keys that you have I forgot to mention
you want to make sure you have all the
keys that you need with you because it's
going to reset all your key fobs so you
have to have all your keys with you and
you have to program them all not just
one so that's why you had to press the
lock on all the keys take the key out
you hear the doors lock that means
you're out of program mode so and then
one key to key and key three they all
work and then the key that I wanted to
program as you can see started the car
so I hope this helped if you liked what
you saw hit that like button you want to
see more hit subscribe take care